I think entrepreneurs or problem
soldiers I think rather than risk takers
yeah
I've become very very interested in the
idea of playing in games that have no
finish lines you will be told your whole
life that you need to learn to listen I
would say that you need to learn to be
the last to speak
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have simon Sinek level
talent add something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference now I started the momentum II
series to try to learn from people
who've done a lot more than us I'm
hopefully by spending a little more time
with them some of their way of thinking
their mindset to believe sink into us to
help us become the best version of
ourselves so today we're going to learn
from one of the best simon Sinek
and five of his most inspiring lessons
also if you want to learn what simon
Sinek and others have to say about
building confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every morning
for the next 250 for mornings i will
send you a 30 second to five-minute clip
on how to build unstoppable confidence
check out the link in the description
below the skill to hold your opinions to
yourself until everyone has spoken does
two things one it gives everybody else
the feeling that they have been heard it
give me gives everyone else the ability
to feel that they have contributed and
two you get the benefit of hearing what
everybody else has to think before you
render your opinion I once had a
one-sided quiet this is a bunch of years
ago
that said what guarantee do I have that
your stuff will work which my answer was
none like I'm giving you a tool you can
it's like a hammer you can use it
broadly or narrowly you can build a
table you can build a house it's the
same tool you can use it for marketing
your music completely revitalize your
entire culture and even though I'm gonna
sell you the most beautiful hammer I'm
not gonna guarantee the instructional
integrity of the house right it's your
business
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one
be a problem-solver I think the word
entrepreneur is bandied about too
loosely mmm that not everyone who owns a
small business as an entrepreneur there
are small business owners and they're
entrepreneurs what's no one's pretty and
you can find entrepreneurs in big
companies it doesn't means that there's
small business owners right I think
entrepreneurs are problem solvers I
think rather than risk takers yeah I
think fundamentally there are plenty of
risk takers I think who aren't
entrepreneur there's a risk taker of
your small business owner right you went
out to start the business but they're
not the same I don't think and
entrepreneurs are those ones who they're
constantly looking to solve problems and
that's where I think they perceive
opportunity or the mischief that you
describe I don't think it's I don't
think inherently it's a sense of
mischief they're not trying to stir the
pot for the sake of stirring the pot I
think that they see something and
they're like we can make that better or
we can fill that hole and that's very
much the way the famous entrepreneurs
the Elon Musk's and the Richard
Branson's operate they see gaps they see
things that don't work as their jobs as
did jobs they see things that could be
better or they it I mean Elon Musk was
just interviewed by Chris Anderson at
Ted last week and Chris Anderson and
sort of near the end of the interview
its online go watch it it's really great
Chris Anderson asks Elon Musk's
something to the effect of why are you
doing all these things like why don't
just stick with Tesla and be done with
it like why do all the other stuff and
you look at and musk you can see this
look on his face and he takes a long
time to answer he actually doesn't
understand the question he cannot
understand why you wouldn't do that and
he sort of gets him Phatak which meal on
musk is pretty amazing because he
doesn't get him Phatak but that's
basically what it is he gets some fat
occurrences cuz I want to live in a
world that's better than this swear
words to that effect you know where I'm
not where the world that we're living
right now makes us unhappy why don't we
want to live in a world that makes us
happy you know he gets sort of he kind
understand and again it's vision first
and that's why he doesn't understand why
you wouldn't try and solve problem
lesson number two have infinite goals
I've become
very very interested in the idea of
playing in games that have no finish
lines right
some games have finish line's right
baseball football right getting a part
is the finish line you audition there's
a beginning middle and end
whose rehearsal and practice there's
showing up for the audition and you
either win or you lose and then it's
over it's over right that is finite but
one's career is infinite there's there's
no end it's like our lives are finite
but life is infinite people come and
people go but life continues right
theater actors come and actors go but
theater continues it's infinite you
don't win theater you win a part but
what happens once you get the part the
the finite game is over now you enter
the infinite game you have to be able to
convert right and the reason this is
important and I've seen this
unfortunately so many times from a young
age all you wanted to do was get to
Broadway and then you get to Broadway
and then what you've devoted your entire
life to one finite goal and when you get
there the immediate response is
depression because I I spent 15 years of
my life for this one thing and I got it
and now I don't know what to do next
like what a get to Broadway again
doesn't have the same ambition
it doesn't have the same passion you
know that you've devoted you from you
know you're from Fargo North Dakota and
that's all you wanted to do is get out
of Fargo and make it to Broadway and you
may eat it right it doesn't have the
same kind of passion and this is because
these are finite goals there's a lot of
studies that have been done with
athletes who have finite goals to become
the greatest X in the world right so
Andre Agassi was one of these one of
these athletes he wanted to become the
greatest tennis player that ever lived
guess what everyone in his life he would
he would view them through how do you
help me get to that everything was how
does this help me get to that everything
was a transaction - how do you help me
move to there and then you know what
happens he achieved that he became the
greatest tennis player in the world and
you know what happened immediately after
depression Michael Phelps set out to
become the most medaled Olympian in
history do you know what he achieved it
you're not happened - immediately after
depression they spend their whole life
working for one goal though most will
never get it the few that do don't know
what to do next because their goals were
finite their goals were finite right and
so there are finite components to your
career but your career should be
infinite so yes of course you have to
win the finite game you have to get the
part but immediately when you get the
part now you convert to infinite lesson
number three be the last to speak Nelson
Mandela is a particularly special case
study in the leadership world because he
is universally regarded as a great
leader you can take other personalities
and depending on the nation you go to we
have different opinions about other
personalities but Nelson Mandela across
the world is universally regarded as a
great leader he was actually the son of
a tribal chief and he was asked one day
how did you learn to be a great leader
and he responded that he would go with
his father to tribal meetings and he
remembers two things when his father
would meet with
other elders one they would always sit
in a circle and to his father was always
the last to speak you will be told your
whole life that you need to learn to
listen I would say that you need to
learn to be the last to speak I see it
in boardrooms every day of the week even
people who consider themselves good
leaders who may actually be decent
leaders will walk into a room and say
here's the problem here's what I think
but I'm interested in your opinion let's
go around the room it's too late the
skill to hold your opinions to yourself
until everyone has spoken does two
things one it gives everybody else the
feeling that they have been heard it
give me it gives everyone else too the
ability to feel that they have
contributed and two you get the benefit
of hearing what everybody else has to
think before you render your opinion the
skill is really to keep your opinions to
yourself if you agree with somebody
don't nod yes if you disagree with
somebody
don't nod no simply sit there take it
all in and the only thing you're allowed
to do is ask questions so that you can
understand what they mean and why they
have the opinion that they have you must
understand from where they are speaking
why they have the opinion they have not
just what they are saying and at the end
you will get your turn
it sounds easy it's not practice being
the last to speak
that's what Nelson Mandela did lesson
number four know your destination
imagine we're standing in a big empty
room right and we're standing in one
corner and I give you a simple
instruction I want you to go to that
corner in a straight line right I'll
figure out no big deal right without
telling you I slip a chair in front of
you what do you do you go around the
chair
now you just disobeyed what I told you
to do I told you to go to that corner
straight line but this is the amazing
things about human beings which is when
we're given a clear destination we use
our own creativity and our own sense of
innovation and our own problem-solving
abilities to overcome obstacles to get
to the destination in other
the destination is more important than
the route right we are flexible about
the route we're obsessed with the
destination reset we're standing in the
corner together and I give you a simple
instruction go somewhere in this room in
a straight line and you say to me well
where do you want me to go I'm like I
don't know
you smart figure it out go in a straight
line and so you pick a point and you
start walking and without telling you I
put a chair in front of you and what do
you do you come to a grinding halt I say
what you stopped for you go will you put
a chair in front of me or you'll make a
sudden turn and go in another direction
right and this is the problem it's the
same obstacle the difference is when you
have a clear set a clear destination the
obstacles become easy to overcome when
you don't have a clear destination you
keep coming to a grinding halt and what
we do in our companies is we're counting
the steps we're taking along the route
but we're never looking at the
destination right so companies has made
a million dollars this year we were only
planning on making eight hundred
thousand like we took ten steps when
you're planning on taking eight where're
you going no clue right we count the
steps and so the point is is that people
want to feel that the effort that
they're exerting actually are moving
somewhere and so successful measurement
successful recognition is not just for
the steps you take it's not just for the
effort it's that the effort you exerted
and moved us closer to where we're
trying to get to and that get to should
be some crazy ideal my ideal is to live
in a world in which the vast majority of
people wake up every single morning
you know inspire to go to work and
fulfilled by the work that they do and
the the couple of measurements that I
use are if the book is selling and I by
the way people ask me how many have you
sold I have no clue I've never asked the
publisher because they don't care I
really don't care how many I've sold
what I care about is the Amazon rankings
and that those are going steady or up
and not plummeting because that means
other people right because I don't have
a publicist I don't have a marketing
strategy on purpose I didn't hire one of
those companies to sell the book for me
and the reason is is because I'm not
interested in book sales I'm interested
the spreading of an idea and so I just
used that as a metric to help me
understand am I sort of marching in that
because the more I preach is it
resonating you know and so you have a
couple of these imperfect measurements
that help you understand are you going
along the way so it's not just great
effort look what you achieved because
that's what we're doing now right our
goal is to increase top-line revenues by
50 million dollars
for what reason right which is we have
to know the destination and then we say
amazing you took us that much closer if
we go to the right it's because we were
overcoming an obstacle if we hadn't gone
to the right we would have been stuck
forever thank you
you know it's not always straight lines
it's not always straight lines but it's
it's in one direction she's pulling the
cane out and lesson number five the last
time before a very special bonus clip is
change your narrative so I wanted to
prove that all marketing was the same
thing Nevada what you were selling it
was always the same thing right and good
marketing talked about the buyer and bad
marketing talked about the seller makes
sense I versus you right so to
illustrate my point I wanted to prove
that what the homeless do and what
Microsoft does is the same thing so if
you think about what the homeless do
there is advertising they sit there with
a little sign that says I'm homeless I'm
hungry I got six kids I'm a veteran like
whatever whatever whatever trying to
appeal to everybody that's called a
little billboard right Microsoft has a
billboard that says more memory bigger
screen all the rest of it right more RAM
or ROM right and what the homeless are
selling is goodwill so if you walk past
a homeless person you put money in their
cup you feel good if you give them
nothing you either feel nothing or feel
bad you paid for that feeling there's an
exchange of consideration I sold you
goodwill you paid for it you got it
right they're selling goodwill that's
what they're doing is selling the
feeling of goodwill so I found a
homeless person who was willing to help
me and her her sign was pretty typical
and I found out that she makes between
twenty and thirty dollars a day selling
goodwill and she works in 8 to 10-hour
day right $30 is considered a good day
right selling goodwill like I said her
sign was pretty typical so I asked if I
could change her sign we did and the
sign that I gave her she made $40 in two
hours the sign that I gave her said if
you only give once a month please think
of me next time
it wasn't about the seller it was about
the giver what are the reasons people
say they don't give how do I know that
they're genuine I can't give to everyone
so I simply answer the questions if you
only give once a month please think of
me next time I know you can't give to
everybody I'm legit that's all right now
here's the point I was gonna make she
could have made $150 that day but after
she made her $40 in two hours she left
because one of the reasons she's
homeless or we could we could surmise
that one of the reasons she's homeless
is she's decided that she needs 20 or
$30 to live per day so once she had it
she moved on that's a narrative it's a
narrative right so she'll stay there
because she didn't sit longer that's a
narrative so there's a wonderful little
trick you can use with your narrative
right
just add the word yet at the end okay
I'll never get I'm not famous yet not
that talented yet I'm so bad and not
good at auditions like I need to get
better at e like I suck at auditions for
now right you can just add a couple of
words of hope or opportunity or the
potential for future or some sort of
infinite component that will profoundly
change your narrative
now we've got a really special bonus
Simon sign and clip on how to serve
others that I really think you're gonna
enjoy but before that I want to make
sure we're moving from watching the
video to actually taking an action in
your life in your business so I've got
three questions for you to think about
write them down for yourself talk about
them with a friend or leave your answers
in the comments below let's move from
consumption to action here we go push
number one what's your biggest infinite
goal that inspires you question number
two how can you practice being the last
to speak this week and question number
three what part of your narrative can
you change to empower yourself thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
so how do you define success I think
successes is is seeing those around you
work to their natural best and creating
momentum for a vision towards a vision
that will last beyond yourself so a guy
is driving a bus for 20 years got to
retire
he's on Madison Avenue in New York
packed every day as people getting on
that bus and getting off mm-hmm his two
kids wife lives in Queens hmm he might
call himself successful another guy
might be vice president of that company
who call self unsuccessful so his
success what you make of it so it's so
this success is defined its successes of
feeling it's not it's not a series of
checkmarks and goals
I think people define success as as
finish lines you know they well I ran a
marathon I'm successful the question is
a why did you run the marathon and what
happens after you've completed the
marathon do you just keep running
marathons what happens if you break your
leg and you can no longer run marathons
you know we said a lot of people set
financial goals I'm successful when I
make my first million okay now I have to
make my second million its success as a
feeling and and it's the feeling of
contribution so your bus driver in
Queens if he has decided that his job as
a bus driver is to ensure that everyone
who gets on his bus feels better about
themselves because they got on his bus
and not another bus and so he greets
them with a smile he says good morning
he says goodbye that people remember
that that that that ride that they took
with him versus the this vice president
of the company who's made it about
himself and his financial goals
he's the one who's unhappy as opposed to
seeing those around him succeed and
those around him go home with a love of
their their day you know because they
come to work in his company every day so
I still believe success and and good
leadership are about service to others
altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think I'm
saying it's a bloody brief life all of
you have the potential for enormous
success if you want to know what Gary
v-d-j Khalid Oprah and others know about
empire building that most people miss
check out the link in the description
for a free bonus video